walk a pin I'm sorry welcome to this
video bling Harlan Steiner from the US
is playing the Budapest I have a
sideline that I play against the
Budapest this one it's maybe not the the
best possible line but it leads to a
position type that I like white always
has good control over d5 and it pretty
much feels like three I'm the Kings
Indian structure I wonder if I should
play you for ya probably I should be for
Bishop e3 should be even should be ok b6
is the bad news because it makes his
pawn structure very very rigid c6 is a
move that you would like to heaven ever
as a possibility against the knight on
d5 and now this is not possible anymore
he has to live with this night or die
with the night if you want Bishop g5 is
now threatened and let's see I could I
could just take it hit he cover g5 which
is she was a good idea ok let's just
take it a play at four this is a good a
good positional set up covering E five
them also preparing Bishop before I
could have played Bishop before
immediately maybe the Sun would have
been better ok but it is a nice position
now I'm looking at this long diagonal
the knight on c6 is not covered
so very likely there are some technical
possibilities like 96 96 something like
that even light b5 a sublime goodness he
needs to protect c7 all the time now but
again I can I can also use the hell yeah
the problem is this structure be six c76
with a knight on d5 this is just
terrible we cannot ever get rid of the
night
yep it's a second the next change from
for absolutely no compensation we do not
see any at least just get the King out
of the way I could have taken on left
five mm-hmm this was much easier but ok
this is as good as well it's just an
exchange who basically have nothing
hmm
yeah I should have just taken on their
five this would have been much easier
King edge one was because I thought okay
Bishop t4 as a possible idea me okay h5
now I can take it was lost anyway check
are you being subject with okay he
needed to take with the porn not blunder
another piece black resigned a disaster
here but then the main point is that
well a fight is still ok but be 6v6 is
just a just a big positional error
because you never get rid of the night
and this is something to think about if
you would play that sin night 86 or 97
you have the idea to play c6 if the
night ever comes to d5 and now with the
night on earth on d5 this always should
should use this function there's always
this pressure here so that c6 is never
possible on of this one he has a really
hard time to prepare that maybe 97 96
you can prepare but it's it's it's a
very weak structure and then the game it
was going downhill really quickly down
here it's difficult to suggest a movie i
also have have this additional IDM to
further increase the pressure i think
it's very likely that black will lose
her upon also bad piece get simply a bad
structure out of the opening + b 6 okay
thanks for watching